Boa noite a todos
[Música]
Boa noite a todos sejam muito bem-vindos
a mais uma live dos apoiadores do canal
Boa noite Rinaldo Evanete e Carlos Por
favor me deem o feedback do
áudio me digam se o áudio está legal
pra gente poder dar aqui seguimento
ok E já vamos responder às dúvidas de
vocês ao
vivo vocês me perdoem se você escutarem
um barulho parecendo um ventilador é que
tô carregando aqui uma bateria na mesma
sala que eu tô fazendo a Live Espero que
não atrapalhe aqui a
transmissão de que o som tá
ok Carlos e Rinaldo vocês também podem
me dar um
feedback e quem mais tiver ao
vivo eu só consigo ver quem tá se
manifestando né Não consigo ver o nome
das pessoas se não se
manifestarem bem vamos lá depois a
gente pegar mais feedback
deixa eu colocar uma outra forma aqui
não não aqui vamos lá vamos às
perguntas tá dando para ler bem aí a as
perguntas
pessoal
tá possível de ler vou tomar a bem daol
você recomenda um comprimido por três ou
cin dias se considera importante tomar
probióticos após o
tratamento geralmente três dias é o
suficiente paraa maioria dos casos tá
Porém isso pode depender do tipo e da
gravidade da
infecção se você tá tomando como
prevenção acho que três dias é o
suficiente então por exemplo tá tratando
para giardia tá tratando para parasitas
com uns TRS dias é o que é habitualmente
utilizado agora tem doenças específicas
é o caso da neuroc
neurocisticercose né que é o mesmo
parasita da at só que no cérebro o
tratamento pode ser até de 28 dias e sim
eh uso de qualquer antiparasitário pode
afetar a
flora pode reduzir o número de bactérias
benéficas deixar a flora mais pobre
então é interessante você tomar os
probióticos sim após o tratamento por
uns 30
dias essa pergunta foi feita pela Kelly
Carvalho próxima pergunta também é da
Kelly boa noite eu gostaria de saber um
comentário a respeito de dodor Anes
naturais já tentei usar porém não deu
muito certo tenho que ter um critério
maior para controlar o aores nas axilas
embora os desodorantes tradicionais
também não sejam assim tão
eficientes após um
período uma vez usei até uma solução
antibiótica já o meu pai não precisa nem
usar desodorante eu não entendo será uma
predisposição sim existe uma
genética específica para TCC tá para ter
cheiro ruim na axila tem uma substância
que é produzida
na no suor que é degradado pelas
bactérias e produz o cheiro ruim tá
tanto que tem algumas etnias lá na Ásia
que não tem cheiro ruim na axila tá e
geralmente o pessoal de descendência
africana tem mais tendência a cheiro
forte do que outras etnias Então isso é
devido à produção de uma substância no
suor que é degradada pelas bactérias e
gera o odor
tá olha eu fiz um vídeo recente sobre
desodorantes tá lá no canal do YouTube
Eu falei de alumínio né e dei várias
opções lá de desodorantes
naturais Com certeza eles são menos
eficientes tá
Infelizmente vai ter que ver com
isso Você já tentou usar o desodorante
de prata
coloidal porque ele tem efeito
antibacteriano não sei se você você
utilizou isso
aí você não tá ao vivo né
Kelly bem vou dar algumas dicas
genéricas aqui manter axilas limpas que
eu acredito que você já
faça usa sabonetes naturais água morna
para limpar a área o Protex pode ser
útil mas tomar cuidado porque uma Ele é
bem
bem químico né Cheio de substâncias
químicas pode experimentar também o óleo
de T3 né de melaleuca não sei se você
tentou utilizar óleo de coco bicarbonato
de sódio o próprio Pat coloidal que eu
já comentei
aqui a dieta pode influenciar o odor
corporal se você ingerir alimentos ricos
enxofre AL cebola isso pode tá
interferindo às vezes usar um probiótico
pode ajudar a diminuir esse cheiro da
axila evitar roupas de material
sintético é um bom estratégia Isso você
já deve estar
fazendo e controle do stresse pode
ajudar a reduzir a produção de suor tá e
consequentemente melhorar o
odor beleza essas dicas que eu tenho
para dar para você mas você não tá ao
vivo né seria interessante você est
aqui o Carlos não Carlos não falou da do
sol não mas Reinaldo falou eu uso o
leite magnésio protege o dia inteiro tá
vendo a dica do Rinaldo Leite magnésio a
gente a gente fala né É uns mais
antigos Já experimentou Leite magnésio
Elly próxima pergunta da Estela Mares
o que que eu acho da hidrocolonterapia
poderia alterar toda uma microbiota
intestinal boa para ruim Boa pergunta
hein
Estela bem vamos explicar para quem não
sabe o que que é isso é uma lavagem
intestinal uma irrigação colônica é um
procedimento que você é submetido à
introdução de água no intestino grosso
para limpar todo o intestino grosso todo
o
cólon então tem vários defensores que
alegam que a hidrocolonterapia Poderia
ajudar a remover várias
toxinas melhorar a saúde
intestinal e eu acredito que sim se a
pessoa tiver com uma disbiose muito
intensa a hidrocolon terapia pode
ajudar mas eu não faria
hidrocolonterapia em todo mundo aí como
tem algumas pessoas que propõe porque
uma pessoa que tá com uma flora
intestinal no intestino grosso boa
certamente você vai bagunçar bastante
esse ecossistema jogando o líquido lá e
jogando todas as bactérias para
fora então pessoa que tem uma disbiose
muito grave eu acho que
a hidrocol terapia pode ser
interessante pessoas que não têm
problemas importantes de disbiose eu não
usaria
Essa é minha opinião tá pra grande
maioria das pessoas Acho que hidrocol
terapia não é uma boa só para pessoas
que tem uma disbiose muito
Severa próxima pergunta da Maria Helena
o que Qual óleo de castanhas posso usar
sem risco de estamina Eu acho que isso
não é um problema porque as castanhas
elas só vão causar reação histamínica se
você ingerir as castanhas Se você passar
óleo de Castanha eu não tô entendendo se
você tá querendo dizer óo de castanho
ingerido ou passar na pele se for passar
na pele não vejo problema nenhum
tá bem a os óleos de nozes como é o caso
do óleo de Castanha do Pará
Eles não tão particularmente ricos em
estamina não mas algumas pessoas podem
ter intolerância sim Se tiverem
tolerancia estamina usando via
oral se você tivesse ao vivo a gente
poderia discutir Maria Helena Por que
que você tá tão preocupada com a questão
da do óo de
castanhas com a questão da intolerância
estamina que eu não lembro terdo
respeito dessa situação específica
não e também para você esclarecer você
tá falando de uso na pele uso externo
tópico ou você tá falando de uso oral né
que você não especificou aqui
né bem a próxima
pergunta leite de alpiste é tudo isso de
bondade que está na internet
Então esse tema tem gado muita
popularidade porque ele tem supostas
propriedades nutricionais benefícios
paraa
saúde porque o alpiste tem muitos
nutrientes como proteínas fibras
vitaminas e minerais e quando você
transforma em leite ele pode ser uma
alternativa ao leite de origem animal é
um dos leites vegetais aí que você pode
utilizar ele tem de fato uma boa
quantidade de proteínas fibras vitaminas
no complexo B vários minerais como
cálcio fósforo potássio Ele é baixo em
calorias é uma alternativa interessante
para quem não pode com lactose ou com
caseína E tem alguns estudos mostrando
que a sementes de alpiste tem compostos
antiinflamatórios que podem ajudar a
reduzir inflamação Então ele pode ajudar
sim mas não é um suplemento
mágico é importante você escolher um
fornecedor desse leite de alí de alta
qualidade então assim eu acho que é uma
boa alternativa sim tá você sabendo
Quais são as limitações desse leite de
alpiste É verdade que se uma pessoa
quebrar o jejum intermitente com
alimentos de alto índice glicêmico todo
o benefício do jejum é revertido Não não
é verdade eh
logicamente que não faz sentido você
fazer um jejum intermitente e depois
comer alimentos inflamatórios mas não
vai quebrar todos os benefícios do jejun
intermitente
não só lembrando aqui as definições o
índice glicêmico refere-se a velocidade
com que um alimento aumenta os níveis de
glicos no sangue tá o termo chave aqui é
velocidade então alimentos de alto
índice glicêmico é o caso de pães
brancos massas refinadas açúcares
processados refinados podem causar Picos
rápidos nos níveis de glicose
insulina e isso vai causar inflamação né
pela resistência
insulínica Porém isso não vai destruir
todos os benefícios do jejum só vai
diminuir os benefícios do jejum não faz
muito sentido você por um lado se
sacrificar para fazer um jejum
intermitente por outro você
ficar quebrando um jejum com alimentos
inflamatórios então para quebrar o jejum
obviamente é recomendável que você opte
por alimentos de baixo índice glicêmico
frutas legumes
tubérculos proteínas magras ou proteínas
gordas contanto que seja uma gordura de
boa
qualidade grãos
certo então não quebra o benefício do
jejum intermitente porém vai diminuir o
benefício em longo
prazo Graviola tomate mamão podde ir na
dieta cetogênica caso o indivíduo não
esteja fazendo exercício
físico tomate tem baixo índice glicêmico
mamão não
Graviola também
não uma porção de graviola vai ter cerca
de 10 a 15 g de carboidratos Então não
vai ser uma coisa legal para uma dieta
cetogênica só se comer bem pouco
Graviola aí se você
comer uma porção você já tá praticamente
fechando a quantidade de carboidratos
que essa
pessoa pode comer num dia né então
porque é cerca de 20 G paraa maioria das
pessoas então Graviola eu não
recomendo mamão também é outra questão
também tem 20 a 25 g de carboidrato por
poção também um problema do da graviola
se a pessoa tivesse fazendo exercício
físico aí poderia tolerar uns 50 g de
carboidrato sem sair da faixa cetogênica
mas sem exercício físico geralmente a
maioria das pessoas vão tolerar só 20
G Tá
bom acho que o Antônio Renato tá ao vivo
né não sei ele não se manifestou ainda
a c Marina pode ser tomada em qualquer
horário Sim pode ser tomada em qualquer
horário
curioso que tá fora de
ordem
Ah não eu pulei aqui eh a di cetogênica
ela e na sua opinião muito deve ser é na
sua opinião né muito eficiente para
doenças mentais como esquizofrenia
depressão e TDH sim eu acho que ela s
ela é bastante eficiente para doenças
mentais
Qual é o número que deve estar numa
parede cetonas para uma pessoa atingir
cetose
terapêutica no mínimo um tá de Beta
hidrox butirato Esses aparelhos que for
o dedo eles medem o Beta hidróxi
butirato at o bhb tem que tá entre um e
qu tá essa que é a faixa
cetogênica 0,5 já tá começando a entrar
cetose mas para uma doença psiquiátrica
eu recomendaria de um a quatro
tá E essas doenças psiquiátricas T muito
a ver com a inflamação cerebral né
quando você faz uma dieta cetogênica
rica em vegetais você reduz bastante a
inflamação cerebral isso vai melhorar a
função cerebral né
agora vamos voltar pro a Marina pode ser
tomada em qualquer
horário sim eu tava respondendo isso né
que sim pode ser tomado em qualquer
horário não vejo nenhum problema agora é
interessante saber o contexto dessa
pergunta para poder responder de uma
forma mais
adequada Por que foi feita dessa forma
Geralmente eu passo el Marina duas vezes
ao dia para tomar de manhã à noite pra
pessoa não esquecer
próxima pergunta
aqui vi que hoje o trump vai investigar
Esse aumento de autismo nos últimos anos
na sua experiência pessoal houve aumento
de casos de autismo nos últimos anos sim
teve isso aí é indiscutível
picada não tenho certeza tá na verdade
já tá aumentando muito antes da picada
aí você colocou um link de um vídeo aqui
na sua visão se bilionários
metacapitalistas quisesse criar uma
caixa que incitasse geneticamente
autismo uma caixa acha que isso seria
biologicamente
possível ou acho que isso Teoria da
Conspiração bem Tem muita coisa que a
gente achava que era a Teoria da
Conspiração e foi sendo provado aos
pouquinhos que não era
né eu creio que esse aumento de casos de
autismo não é proposital é por causa da
toxicação ambiental Principalmente as
toxinas ambientais por causa também das
picadas em modo geral eu acho que é uma
causa apesar de ser tem uma
Tabu e também tem a ver
com a parte nutrição né Eu acho que a
queda da qualidade nutricional aí de
vários alimentos agora não entendi bem o
que is qu dizer com caixa que citasse
geneticamente
autismo eu não acho que seja
interessante para os globalistas terem
crianças autistas viu o que é
interessante no meu no meu ponto de
vista seria as pessoas serem alienadas
mentalmente
dependentes financeiramente do governo
né eles querem destruir a economia de
vários países aí para deixar as pessoas
dependentes do governo e aumentar o
controle mas eu não consigo eu nunca
ouvi nenhuma Pelo menos eu nunca ouvi
nenhuma teoria falando
que os globalistas ou dominadores
globais achassem interessante muitas
crianças com autismo por algum motivo
específico tá você tá aí Vivo quem que
mandou essa pergunta deixa eu
ver Antônio
Renato bem vamos ver as perguntas ao
vivo aqui
novamente Boa noite a
todos o Reinaldo comentando novamente
sobre o leite
magnésio só que
a a Keila não tá aqui né para interagir
com a gente véspera de feriado né
pessoal para pelo menos tá de São
Paulo Então acho que a tendência essa
Live ter menos gente
mesmo Desculpa falei Keila mas é Kelly o
nome da da moça que fez a pergunta lá do
desodorante É verdade que tem sín
fúngica não pode comer banana muito
madura deve evitar Eliseu Porque
qualquer fonte de frutose e glicose vai
ajudar a aumentar o fungo intestinal tá
não é que é proibido mas deve evitar
qualquer fruta
doce mamão não pode nem mesmo na dialoc
carb que Dirá cetogênica é É
verdade
ã 500 mg de C Marina 60 cápsula você
pode tomar essa dose aí de uma a duas
vezes por dia
tá caixa igual Ah tá caixa é
isso então eu não acho que as picad
tenham provocado não
tá quer
dizer aí a pergunta é se as picadas
foram propositalmente colocadas para
aumentar
autismo eu acho que elas estão
aumentando sim mas eu não creio que seja
proposital eu acho que eles queriam era
aumentar a morbidade geral da
população mas não necessariamente essa
doença
específico
Ah tá beleza Antônio
o aumento de autismo tem alguma coisa a
ver com a exposição ao sol cada vez
menor tem a ver mas eu acho que não é um
fator tão importante não Eliseu Mas tem
a ver sim vitamina D é o imuno regulador
né quem tem fígado gordo pode fazer uso
das gorduras boas sem discriminação não
depende depende tá tudo em excesso é
ruim se a pessoa tiver comendo uma
quantidade absurda de gordura vai dar
problema é que a gordura é muito
saciante né então Geralmente quem faz
dieta cetogênica não engorda é muito
difícil porque a pessoa fica saciada não
consegue nem comer
mais mas se a pessoa tiver com um fígado
muito gordo e ela exagerar muito na
gordura pode dar problema apesar de ser
raro isso
acontecer Qual que é a dosagem segura da
El lisina até 3 G por dia tranquilamente
viu Evanete 3 G
Talvez o aumento de crianças autistas
seja interessante para vender mais
remédios é esse
raciocínio pode fazer
sentido Só que eu acho que aumenta tanto
os custos né Eh muita criança autista aí
aumenta demais o custo né pra sociedade
então não sei se isso é tão
interessante dentro das teorias de que
os globalistas querem diminuir a
população mundial não sei se faria
sentido ter tanta gente doente
dependente do governo aumentando os
custos que um autista Teoricamente tem
uma expectativa de vida igual a uma
pessoa normal né então ia ficar
aumentando o custo por muito
tempo não sei se encaixa nas teorias que
eu conheço não sim reduzir população não
necessariamente tornar a população
doente dependente de de gast
governamentais né porque o autista Como
eu disse vai ter uma expectativa de vida
normal né o o Down que tem uma
expectativa de vida
menor vocês têm mais perguntas ao vivo
pessoal deixa eu ver acho que eu ten um
artigo que eu separei pra gente discutir
hoje enchar aqui
Hã Não sei se eu já discuti a questão do
probiótico para
TDH vocês querem ouvir sobre um um
estudo sobre qual é o mínimo de
exercício físico necessário para manter
a forma
física que que vocês acham
eu acho que Esso não discuti com vocês
ainda
tá vou esperar vocês responderem três
colheres de Ace de oliva e duis de óleos
de coco e excesso de gordura diária Ah
tá perguntando se é excesso três
colheres de azeite de oliva e duas de
óleo de coco não não é excesso não não é
excesso não Reinaldo e Antônio Renato
disseram sim então vamos lá então tem um
estudo interessante que
tenta responder uma pergunta qual é o
mínimo de exercícios físicos necessários
para manter a forma
física Então esse estudo bem
interessante investigou Exatamente isso
no grupo das mulheres jovens então
pesquisadores conduziram um estudo para
entender como diferentes frequência de
treino afetam a manutenção de massa
muscular força e capacidade aeróbica
após 12 semanas de Treinamento combinado
de resistência que é de força né E
exercícios aeróbicos eles queriam saber
se é possível manter os ganhos de
condicionamento físico com menos treinos
então o estudo envolveu 34 mulheres
jovens sem experiência de Treinamento
com idade média de 20 anos e sem
problemas de saúde aparentes então isso
garantiu que os resultados fossem devido
ao protocolo de treinamento e não a
outros
fatores então inicialmente todas as
participantes passaram por 12 semanas de
Treinamento
combinado como eu falei força e aeróbico
né resistência aeróbico duas vezes por
semana Cada sessão Durava cerca de 1
hora incluir exercícios de resistência
como leg press que esse daí é o clássico
né geralmente quando
tudo para ver fibra muscular é sempre
preciso de
perna exercícios também aeróbicos
intensos em bicicleta
ergométrica então era uma sessão de uma
hora duas vezes semana exercício de
resistência e exercícios aeróbicos
intensos em bicicleta ergométrica após
as 12 semanas as participantes foram
divididos em três grupos um grupo que
treinou só uma vez por semana mantiveram
o mesmo treino de uma hora por dia mas
reduziram a frequência para uma vez por
semana o outro
continuou aliás continuou não é o teve o
segundo grupo que treinou uma vez a cada
duas
semanas reduziram a frequência para uma
vez a cada duas semanas quer dizer um
grupo que tava fazendo duas vez semana
passou para uma vez semana outro grupo
uma vez a cada duas semanas e o terceiro
Grupo Sem
treino Então essas condições foram
mantidas por mais 12 semanas então
depois disso todos os grupos pararam de
treinar por completo por mais 12 semanas
totalizando 36 semanas de estudo Tá
então vamos de novo para não ficar
confuso 12 semanas duas vezes semana
12 semanas duas vezes por semana depois
disso três grupos por 12 semanas um
grupo que fez uma vez semana grupo uma
vez a cada duas semanas e um grupo não
fez nada aí foram mais 12
semanas todo mundo sem treinar tá bom
Espero que não tenha ficado
confuso então o grupo que fez a
manutenção uma vez semana com treino ele
conseguiu manter todos os ganhos de
força massa muscular e Cap aeróbica
obtidos nas primeiras 12 semanas que
todo mundo tá treinando duas vezes
semana um treino uma vez por semana
Desculpa um treino uma vez a cada duas
semanas houve uma diminuição de 5% na
força 6% na massa muscular e 10% na
capacidade aeróbica o grupo sem treino
apresentou as maiores pdas né como Era
óbvio com reduções de 14% na força 7% na
massa muscular e 16% na capacidade
aeróbica então após as últimas 12
semanas sem nenhum treinamento todos os
grupos sofreram perdas
significativas retornando quase aos
níveis iniciais de de
condicionamento então o que que
significa esses resultados eles sugerem
que é possível manter os ganhos de
condicionamento físico com apenas uma
sessão de treino intensa TRE
intensa uma sessão de treino intensa por
semana no entanto treinar apenas uma vez
a cada duas semanas não é o suficiente
para manter a
forma especialmente em termos de
capacidade aeróbica Então pessoal se
vocês tiverem tempo fazer só uma vez por
semana vale a pena uma vez a cada duas
semanas não vale a
pena eu recomendo para as pessoas no
mínimo três vezes por semana atividade
física
o ideal é cinco Mas vamos dizer que as
pessoas não t tempo nenhum faz um um
treino intenso uma vez semana foi esse
que esse estudo disse aqui
tá vale a pena para quem não tá fazendo
nada
e tem uma pergunta aqui do Eliseu existe
uma tabela de todos os suplementos que
se chocam se ingeriam um perto do outro
não não tem Eliseu
até porque como é que você vai fazar uma
tabela com milhares de coisas né Ia
ficar uma tabela tão gigantesca que
ninguém ia conseguir entender essa
tabela
né
certo eu acho que seria uma coisa
interessante para você treinar uma ia
uma llm né uma large language Model o
modelo de linguagem
para estudar Isso daí seria uma coisa
interessante
eu acho que seria um um bom caso para
treinar uma um modelo de linguagem com
isso pelo que aprendi fazer exercícios
só duas vezes ou menos por semana é
prejudicial Olha eu não acho que seja
prejudicial não tá esse estudo tá
falando que não não Ele tá dizendo que é
uma coisa interessante sim se você
tivesse só tem para fazer uma vez semana
só eu acho que você tá falando é dos
Weekend Warriors que é outra situação
Carlos tá vamos lá o que nós estamos
falando aqui é treinar uma hora por dia
um treino intenso mas não é intenso a
ponto do cara se matar tá o que você tá
falando aqui que eu tô entendendo aqui
que você tá dizendo é que tem gente que
pega uma vez por semana e vai andar de
bicicleta 4 horas na rodovia
aí é intenso demais o que eu tô falando
desse estudo é uma hora só por semana
não são 4 horas aí eu concordo com você
se for um exercício físico intenso e
prolongado uma vez semana vai ser ruim
pra saúde sim mas esse estudo tava
falando de uma hora só de exercício
físico por semana não era 4 horas Não
beleza Ficou claro isso
aí mais perguntas
Pessoal vocês querem que eu discute mais
um artigo com vocês
aqui ou vocês querem que eu
responda as
perguntas esperar um pouco que vocês
responderem ah
m
entre algum assunto interessante como
alimentação saudável e seus
benefícios só agora consegui entrar mas
o assunto realmente é muito importante
certamente Vou ver depois é Rosa Depois
você dá uma olhada
você ouviram falar da lipoproteína a a
LPA não é o apolipoproteína A1 tô
falando da lipoproteína a que era um
grande desafio no tratamento porque não
tinha nenhum medicamento nenhum
suplemento que
baixasse isoladamente o
LPA tinha um protocolo bem complicado
para baixar LPA que é um fator de risco
independente para doença
cardiovascular mas é um protocolo bem
complicado a medicina funcional aí eu
quero falar para vocês de uma notícia
interessante de uma droga que foi
desenvolvida para baixar o
LPA nossa célula se renovam a cada 30
dias
eh Por que que você tá colocando essa
informação
aqui bem vamos lá a LPA ou lipoproteína
a é uma doença genética relacionada à
gordura do sangue tá não é a mesma coisa
que LDL colesterol HDL colesterol
triglicérides é uma lipoproteína isolada
que é um risco de saúde isolado Também
quem tem LPA aumentado Independente de
ter LDL bom ou HDL bom tem o risco
aumentado para doença cardiovascular
então a LPA ou lipoproteína a é uma
partícula de colesterol cuja
concentração é geneticamente determinada
então ao contrário de outros tipos de
colesterol que depende da atividade
física da dieta do estilo de vida os
níveis de LPA tendem a permanecer
estáveis ao longo da vida e não
respondem a mudanças de estilo de vida
então altos níveis de LPA acima de
125 nanomoles por litro promove
inflamação aumenta a coagulação eleva o
risco de condições graves como ataque
cardíaco né o infarto derrame até
estenose
aórtica Então o que torna esse problema
ainda mais alarmante é que por volta de
20% da população Global apresenta níveis
elevados de LPA sendo mais prevalente
entre as pessoas de ascendência africana
e Su asiática E como eu falei não existe
nenhum tratamento até hoje aprovado para
reduzir os níveis de LPA porém chegou um
Rem medicamento novo que ainda não sei
dos efeitos colaterais tá só tô passando
a notícia para vocês que chama
muvin
muvin é o primeiro medicamento oral
desenvolvido para combater diretamente
LPA el torna de uma maneira inovadora
quebrando a ligação entre as duas partes
da partícula de
LPA reduzindo seus níveis de forma
significativa essa abordagem é
completamente diferente das outras
terapias né como er o
caso dos Remédios mais caros para
colesterol que eram injetáveis então de
acordo com step nichols que é o
pesquisador líder e diretor do victorian
Heart institute o muva la plin traz uma
esperança inédita para uma uma cição que
era até agora intocável então os
resultados preliminares do estudo kaken
ou kraken que o nome daquele bichão né
quem é que se lembra daquele filme
antigão que tinha né de Stop Motion que
tinha o kraken né que era um monstrão lá
da mitologia grega né então o nome do
estudo é kraken então os resultados
desse estudo mostraram que a pílula né
do mval plin poderia ser um visor de
águas no tratamento das doenças
cardiovasculares relacionadas ao
LPA Então esse estudo kraken recrutou
233 pacientes ao redor do mundo Todos
com níveis extremamente Altos de LPA
acima de 175 nanomoles por litro esses
participantes foram divididos em grupos
que receberam doses deáreas de 10 60 ou
240 MG de mval
aplin ou ainda Placebo durante 12
semanas Então os pesquisadores usaram
dois tipos de teste de sangue para pedir
os níveis de LPA um padrão e outro mais
avançado capaz de detectar partículas
intactas Então os resultados foram
interessantes foram impressionantes o
movva Lapin reduziu os níveis de LPA em
até
85% com o novo teste e 97% dos
participantes atingiram níveis abaixo de
125 Além disso essa droga foi
considerada segura e bem tolerada vamos
ver no futuro como como é que vai ficar
isso aí né Por enquanto estão dizendo
que é seguro e
tolerado é óbvio que se é um trabalho
preliminar tem que fazer vários outros
estudos maiores e mais longos para ver a
segurança mesmo disso daí e
eficácia e se de fato vai diminuir os
eventos finais né que são o infarto e o
avci né AVC
isquêmico porém alguns especialista como
é o caso do er Michel da Universidade
John Hopkins que é uma das principais
Estados Unidos de medicina acreditam que
o moval plin é um passo
evolucionário Então vamos ficar
acompanhando aí para ver se esse
maplin não vai dar um problemão sério lá
na frente né
mval Que nome esquisito né
Por que que os alimentos saudáveis se
transformam em nossas
células Não entendi isso
aqui desculpa não
entendi conheço um idoso que todo dia
corre na praia não falta um dia sequer é
todo dia mesmo é o único exercício que
ele faz mesmo praticando esse exercício
todo dia ele vai pegar sarcopenia
confere
não não necessariamente Era bom que ele
além de de correr que ele fizesse
musculação nas pernas também eu faria
dessa forma mas não necessariamente ele
vai ter sarcopenia não até porque por
mais que ele faça um exo aeróbico ele tá
fazendo exo com as pernas né então ele
vai Mater massa muscular na perna não
tão eficiente quanto musculação
obviamente vi uma notícia que
tem de que tem que se uma pessoa tiver
uma CV deve ser uma AVC né ela tem 3
horas antes de ficar com sequelas é
verdade isso Antônio é verdade tem 3
horas para chegar ao Hospital e ser
submetido a uma terapia trombolítica
para não ficar com sequela isso não é
mentira
não OK vou esperar tá você reformular
sua
pergunta depende da célula a célula do
intestino delgado se renova a cada TRS
dias e tem célula no cérebro que demora
anos para se renovar Então não é toda a
célula que é 30 dias não
tá o que deve ser feito S uma pessoa
descobrir ou desconfiar de AVC deve ir
imediatamente pro hospital né e de
preferência hospital de terciário né que
vai ter condições de fazer a terapia
fibrinolítica paraa pessoa não ter
sequela né então tem que ser um hospital
de nível
terciário exatamente AVC isquêmica é a
mesma
coisa é muito parecido na verdade a
única diferença do AVC isquêmico pro
infarto é o tipo de
território infarto é coronária e o AVC
isquêmicos são artérias do cículo do
polígono de willes né do cérebro essa
que é a diferença mas é a mesma coisa
entupimento da artéria levando a
isquemia e morte celular que muda só o
território
mas se foral do interior tá lascado
Antônio basicamente tá lascado depende
do interior né Se for interior rico tipo
Campinas é uma coisa né Agora se for
interior do sei lá do Pará é outra
história
né não tenho nenhum preconceito Pará
adoro o Estado do Pará tá estô sei lá
vamos colocar o estado aí eh interior de
maranão sei lá
né Bem pessoal Estamos indo para 45
minutos de Live acho que tá Tá bom já né
ã naturalmente não tem
opções nos hospitais é isso
estou com varises internas está
alastrando na perna direita e ficando
escuro tem algum suplemento bom para
isso tem a castanha da Índia tem a
esperidina com a Diosmina tá no
documento sobre isso você PR olhar no
documento lá
do dos do pessoal recebe quando entra no
grupo do do YouTube tá lá falando tem
uma uma sessão lá que é sobre
suplementos para variz
interior do Ceará também né de qualquer
estado aí que seja mais menos
desenvolvido
né novamente o Ceará é um estado que eu
adoro também tá não é preconceito contra
Maranhão Ceará nem Pará não só tô dando
como
exemplo bem acho que tá na hora de
encerrar né pessoal tem mais perguntas
de nada
Sara é Sara
né não é Sara ae né Sara aí fica sarada
aí fica sarada aí Sara aí é Sara né
confirma para mim se fala
Sara bem Boa noite a todos Obrigado pela
presença de
vocês e a gente se fala na próxima
semana